[Music]
Narrator: Adélie penguins near the Ross Sea
are frequently on the move,
waddling and sliding along icy surfaces,
not to mention breeding or hunting for food.
Their Antarctic home can experience
whiteout conditions from snow and freezing rain
and winds upwards of 90-100 miles per hour.
This leaves drones and helicopters tight flight windows
to observe penguin colonies from above.
New research, published in Science Robotics,
took advantage of this challenge
to test an automated technique for piloting
drones in extreme environments.
Its flight path algorithm was shown to speed
up penguin surveys more than tenfold.
The algorithm, affectionately dubbed POPCORN,
uses a mathematical system to navigate tricky environmental barriers
in ways that human-piloted drones haven’t.
Rather than the zigzagging “lawnmower”
pattern of individually flown drones
POPCORN takes a contoured path over a targeted area,
and layers the paths of multiple drones.
This helps preserve battery life while maintaining survey coverage.
The study scientists aimed their sights at Cape Crozier,
one of the largest Adélie penguin colonies in the world
with more than 300,000 nesting pairs.
The algorithm set its course by designing a grid of the target area
and assigning GPS coordinates to points on the grid.
Satellite elevation data prevented drones
from colliding with each other
and the varying slopes of Cape Crozier.
This data also helped meet strict regulations
on airspace over penguin colonies
and ensure the safety of the Cape’s tuxedoed residents.
And POPCORN fixed the path’s start and stop
positions in the same place
to simplify the search for a safe landing site.
All of this, the researchers claim,
made the aerial survey as easy as pressing a button.
Previously, human-piloted drone surveys of
this region took over two days to complete.
The new, automated drone network accomplished
the task in three hours.
Ecologists hope this technique will
provide better estimates of penguin populations than
individual drones and satellite imagery.
And, for the first time, allow large aerial surveys of their chicks,
which are currently counted on the ground—beak by beak.
Adélie penguins also indicate changes in climate.
Their hunting movements and breeding success
are smoking guns for sea ice transformations in Ross Sea.
The research team has already deployed its technology
to help track bird movements in California
and livestock on ranches.
One day, the team envisions POPCORN contributing to wildfire surveys,
its swift operations detecting vulnerable areas of forest and brush
under intense time pressure.
As climate change and conservation
force us to rethink the way we see the world
this eye in the sky could prove a handy, hands-free tool.
[Music]